si la vérité normalement il n'ya pas à
réfléchir qui s'apprête aventure mais
vous non alors maxime j'ai plein de
talent expressément pour toi le
détecteur de mons mais non tu vas venir
me rejoindre et tu vas être face à
l'animal il va devoir dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
maxime je t'attends tu as d
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ces volumes sont vos trucs
ce qui est bien c'est que hier j'avais
posé une question la vie répond non non
on respecte son intimité aujourd'hui
surtout de la 4c vous dérange vous ne
servez votre coeur
[Rires]
maxime céline je vais te poser une
première question pour voir si le
détecteur de mention de marche bien le
cerro maxime
série
est-ce que tu t'appelles maxime je
m'appelle maxime tu dois dire oui
alors oui c'est bon tout est sous
contrôle
première question
est-ce que maxime tu es en couple
actuellement
oui
[Musique]
maxime
est ce que la personne ait dans le
milieu des médias
non c'est là qu'elle soit après vous
avez témoigné je suis ce qu'on peut
répéter la wii je pensais la régie est
rare d'avoir mère de maxime
[Applaudissements]
est ce que la personne qui est en couple
avec vous
un rapport avec la radio la télévision
ou autre chose
ap
non
oui autre chose en disant autre chose en
même temps à chasser moubarak s'est
ouvert quand même un maxime est ce que
vous êtes en couple et aka personnes
depuis plus de six mois
oui
est-ce que vous avez mis papa dans maman
malade assure d'abord six mois est-ce
que vous avez mis papa dans maman martin
mais là aussi on va dire sérieux est-ce
que vous avez mis le zizi dans la csn
vous avez mis le kiki dans le freestyle
[Applaudissements]
je répète la question qui dans frichti
j'adore les montagnes russes maintenant
mais on n'était pas là pouf allemagne
les experts devront soigner comment ça
m'a coûté cette bagnole euros m e toiba
est ce qu'il ya eu
zizi dans ces êtres uniques non dits
dans dix ou non il m'a si c'est
impossible
quoi quoi six mois non mesdames en
vitamines j'attends donc si mon nom
alors donc là pour l'instant donc
c'était injuste galocher mais selon le
le détecteur un détecteur il ya eu 6
août aux nazis bientôt anciennement
peut-être qu'américains c'est parce
qu'ils y sont réalisées ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
dégagez tue pas aux 45 minutes en facial
à cela ça va causer le brésil pas bravo
à l'éveil la france pensait déjà au
mariage
ah non alors ça c'est vrai c'est
d'ailleurs si vous voulez être le témoin
peut-être à chaque fois j'ai été témoin
d'un mariage ils ont divorcé anna corps
alors effacé d'autres expériences
maxime vieu de poser une dernière
question
oh cela je vais faire le tour
maxime
est-ce que
je connais oui ou non la personne
réfléchit bien nous pataugeons réfléchis
bien si mal savoir la vérité
normalement il n'a pas réfléchi et oui
et qui s'arrêtent aventure ouais mais
vous non voilà ce qui hier cyril a dit
qu'il la connaissait le maxi oui était
donné
je vais le laisser comme ça
[Musique]
oh
la maxime gainer vous êtes libre jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
merci monsieur procureur ce qui va se
passer c'est que je verrai cuire toutes
ces réponses le faire l'analyse de cette
séquence ce soir chez moi et demain vous
aurez droit à une enquête de baba qui
dit en quête de baba dix résolutions de
la faire et ça va très bien vous qui
êtes un désaveu affaires n'hésite pas à
les faire au cours de cette émission
parce que demain il sera déjà trop tard
[Musique]